trois opérations en quatre jours
quatorze personnes en garde à vue et
pour clôturer cette folle semaine
plusieurs condamnations pour trafic de
stupéfiants d'abord 9 dijonnais
comparaissait ce vendredi
au moins deux d'entre eux ont écopé de
peines de prison avec sursis ou à
domicile avec surveillance électronique
par ailleurs cinq personnes ont été
jugés et condamnés cet après midi
notamment dans le volet sur les armes
celles exhibé au brésil le lundi 15 juin
ce sont des gens qui effectivement
participé à cet attroupement au cours
duquel il y a eu un certain nombre de
violences un certain nombre de
dégradations qui ont été commises
mais l'infraction qui leur est reproché
le fait d'avoir participé à cet
attroupement avec des armes j'indique
qu'il ne s'agit en ce qui les concerne
pas d'armes à feu ni factice ni réelle
mais il s'agissait d'armes plutôt par
destination de type bâtons barres de fer
ou autre la peine encourue est de cinq
ans d'emprisonnement
voilà ce qu'on leur reproche en
parallèle notre enquête se poursuit
concernant ces images si certaines de
ces armes sont factices mais ces scènes
ont choqué interpellé il fallait aller
vite
justement les descentes de cette semaine
ont permis de retrouver plusieurs armes
réelles et près d'un millier de
munitions dont une cartouche de
kalachnikov une découverte n'est pas
vraiment une surprise on découvre pas
maintenant qu'il y a des armes sur le
territoire national très régulièrement
nous faisons des saisies d'armes ensuite
le contexte actuel a mis en lumière au
travers de ce qui s'est passé c'est le
jour des gens qui étaient
majoritairement munis de bâtons et
quelques-uns d'armes réelles ou factices
ces premières condamnations apporte une
réponse pénale à court terme mais dans
les semaines qui viennent un groupe
local de traitement de la délinquance
sera mis en place
sorte de cellule de crise axées sur le
quartier des grésillés
et sur la question des armes et du
trafic de stupéfiants